Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Im Rahmen des Mercedes-Benz Junior Cups in Sindelfingen hatte ich die Möglichkeit mit einigen Trainern über Jugendfußball zu sprechen. Das hört ihr jetzt in dieser etwas besonderen Folge des Kurzpasses. Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, im letzten Jahr schon habe ich eine Episode, einen Kurzpass beim Junior Cup in Sindelfingen produziert. Und damals auch schon den Hinweis vorausgeschickt, den ich jetzt auch nochmal platzieren möchte, ich war da nicht primär für den Rasenfunk, sondern beruflich. Das heißt, ich habe da noch einen kleinen Job, einen sehr schönen Job, einer der letzten meiner Tätigkeiten aus meiner alten Selbstständigkeit, der ich nachgehe. Und dementsprechend sei an der Stelle eben der Hinweis gemacht, wenn euch das stört, dass ich da quasi beruflich war und das primär mit dem Rasenfunk erst mal nichts zu tun hatte, der ja auch werbe- und sponsorenfrei ist, dann hört diese Folge nicht. Ich empfehle euch, hört sie. Und ihr könnt ja besonders genau hinhören, ob ich vielleicht diesem Turnier besonders positiv gegenüberstehe, weil ich eben da auch mit vielen netten Menschen tatsächlich zusammenarbeite und eben auch einen kleinen Teil meines Geldes darüber verdiene. Also dieser Hinweis sei vorausgeschickt und noch einiges anderes sollte ich zu dieser Folge erklären. Es ist ein bisschen eine besondere Folge, denn sie setzt sich zusammen aus mehreren Einzelgesprächen, die ich führen konnte. Es gab eine Art Mixed Zone, in der man die Möglichkeit hatte, mit den Trainern der beteiligten Teams zu sprechen. Es waren vor Ort zum Beispiel der FC Liverpool, der FC Bayern, Hertha BSC, VfB Stuttgart, Atlanta United, die Glasgow Rangers und Rapid Wien gewonnen hat das Turnier Liverpool. Dazu gibt es dann auch noch mal eine extra Folge, wobei wir das damals noch nicht wussten. Erklär ich euch am Ende dieses Kurzpasses. Der Rahmen war dann ebenso, wie er in einer Mixed Zone auch ist. Das heißt, die Trainer haben sich platziert in einem kleinen Raum und dann hatte jeder Journalist, jeder Journalistin, jeder Blogger, jeder Influencer, wer auch immer da alles vor Ort war, die Möglichkeit, mit den Trainern ein Gespräch zu führen. Ich habe mir dann diejenigen geschnappt, die gerade Zeit hatten, weil ich versuchen wollte, auch in diesem Rahmen ein bisschen die Rasenfunkatmosphäre zumindest teilweise herzustellen. Das heißt, zu versuchen, ein etwas tiefer gehendes Gespräch zu führen. Ich dachte, es wäre dafür ganz gut, wenn ich mir quasi nicht die Gesprächspartner mit Journalisten und Kollegen teilen muss, weil sie sich dann eben ganz auf meine Fragen konzentrieren können. Dementsprechend ist es auch eine interessante Auswahl geworden. Ihr werdet jetzt drei Gespräche hören, ich werde sie jeweils kurz ankündigen und dann einfügen. Zuerst mit Tony Annan, dem Leiter der Nachwuchsakademie von Atlanta United. Mit ihm habe ich über einige interessante Dinge gesprochen. Das ist auch das längste Gespräch geworden. Dann hörte noch Michael Hartmann, Trainer der U19 von Hertha BSC und am Ende Nico Willig, Trainer der U19 des VfB Stuttgart. Und eine Anmerkung dazu noch, weil das im Rahmen einer Mixed-Song passiert ist, ist die Tonqualität logischerweise auch anders, als ihr es im Rasenfunk gewohnt seid. Das heißt, im Hintergrund gibt es immer wieder Geräusche. Ich hoffe, sie stören nicht zu sehr. Ich habe so viel rausgefiltert, wie noch zu machen war. Ich hoffe, es ist für euch dennoch interessant. Beim Abhören hat die Qualität bei mir ausgereicht, dass ich es in allen Situationen hören konnte. Ich hoffe, euch geht es ähnlich. Jetzt würde ich aber sagen, legen wir los. Als erstes folgt das längste von allen drei Gesprächen. Das ist auch die Reihenfolge, in der ich sie gehalten habe, an diesem Abend. Vielleicht erkennt ihr auch ein Muster in der Moderation. Ich musste mich auch selbst erstmal ein bisschen anpassen an diese Situation. Jetzt hören wir Tony Annan von Atlanta United. Ich habe ihn ein bisschen über das Turnier ausgefragt, aber es ging mir dann viel eher um die Jugendarbeit bei Atlanta United und in den USA generell. Ich habe da auch an viele Dinge angeknüpft, die euer Feedback waren zu unserer Folge mit Jürgen Kalver zur MLS und dem Sieg von Atlanta United im Meisterschaftsfinale. Ich habe versucht, da ein bisschen anzuknüpfen, ein paar Fragen zu stellen, auch ein paar Anmerkungen zu machen, die ihr noch hattet. Und ich fand, dass wirklich ein sehr interessantes Gespräch draus geworden ist. Man konnte Tony Annan wirklich jede Frage hinwerfen. Er hat auf jede sehr, sehr sportlich und sehr interessant reagiert. Und ich fand, er hat auch an gewissen Punkten kein Blatt vor den Mund genommen. Das empfand ich als sehr angenehm. Aber jetzt wird einfach selber rein. Es geht los mit Tony Annan von Atlanta United.
Es ist wirklich spannend, es ist sehr gut, die Standards sind toll. Es ist ein sehr gutes Entwicklungsstück für unsere Spieler, vor dem Publikum zu spielen. Wir spielen natürlich alle gemeinsam ein anderes Kind von Fußball, denn wir spielen nicht Indoor-Soccer, mit Boards.
Ist es so jung wie ein Club?
Wir haben die Barsche ziemlich hoch gesetzt. Und im zweiten Jahr sind wir wieder im Finale. Dieses Jahr hoffen wir, dass wir wieder zurückkommen. Wir haben in drei Jahren acht Spieler aus unserer Akademie ausgeschlossen, in die Reserve-Team und die erste Team. Aber jetzt sind wir unter 12, 13, 14, mit den ersten, so zu sagen, our-Players, Atlanta United-Players. Also werden wir hoffentlich in den nächsten drei, vier Jahren einiges mehr von diesen sehen.
Also arbeiten wir sehr hart, mit den ersten Team-Playern von dort zu entwickeln. Und wie rekrutierst du deine Spieler aus nichts? Hast du ein Scouting-System?
Ich war in der Stadt seit 20 Jahren. Und seit unser Erfolg und die Akademie vollfündet und sehr gut nachgeschaut wurde, können wir die Spieler in unserer Stadt, in unserem Land bekommen. Wir haben 7 Millionen Menschen in der Metro Atlanta. Aber unsere Entstehenden werden viel besser werden. Und unser Pool in Atlanta ist sehr divers. Wir haben viele Ethnische und viele Nationalitäten.
Wir haben einen rischen Pool.
Und manche sagen, dass Jürgen Klinsmann ein großes Problem ist, für den US-Soccer.
Wenn College-Soccer eine neun Monate langen Saison war, könnte die Entwicklung weitergehen. Aber ich glaube, dass es nur ein Problem ist, eine viermonatige Saison zu sein und dann sechs bis sieben Monate auszulassen. Oder nicht-kompetitiv-Soccer, nicht-kompetitiv-Training. In den nächsten zehn Jahren wird viel mehr Talent direkt in die professionellen Rangungen gehen. Und Fogo College.
Aber ist es kein Problem, dass die Spieler dann die Beziehung oder die professionelle Sportart entscheiden müssen?
Also gibt es jetzt mehr Incentive in den Beträgen. Ich hoffe so. Wir sind auch sehr interessiert in der Bildschirme.
Genau, das sind die einzigen, die wir signieren.
Es ist nicht fair, diese Möglichkeit auf einem 50-50-Gesetz zu nehmen. Wir müssen sicher sein, dass der Spieler den Potenzial hat, sich durchzuschauen. Es gibt also Optionen.
Und wie denkst du, dass du in einer langen Geschichte mit den großen USA-Sporten in den nächsten 5-10 Jahren mit der Sport-Wahl in der USA-Spielzeit mitkommen kannst?
Wie denkst du, dass du mit der NFL mit der Sport-Wahl in der USA-Spielzeit mit der NFL oder mit dem Fußball.
Mit der Europäischen Liga mit der MLS immer mit der MLS mit der Europäischen Liga mit der Europäischen Liga? Und nur im zweiten oder dritten Platz ist es wichtig, wie kompetitiv man sich mit den europäischen Liga vergleicht. Aber was denkst du, ist das ein Thema, das in den USA diskutiert wird?
Ich glaube, dass unsere Liga nicht die Liga, die Premier League oder die Bundesliga ist. Ich sehe viel Fußball und ich denke, wenn es eine Begabeltruppe zwischen den Liga und der Bundesliga gibt, wird es die Bundesliga sein.
Ich denke, dass die Hälfte der MLS-Klubs in der Bundesliga spielen und ganz gut spielen können.
Aber ich denke, dass die Hälfte der MLS-Klubs, die guten Fußball spielen, die taktisch akut sind, in den europäischen Liga spielen können.
Ist es wichtig für dich, weil ich nicht sicher bin, ob es eine europäische Perspektive ist, die MLS-Klubs in den Liga zu vergleichen.
Ja und nein. Es wird diskutiert, aber ich denke, die USA sind so konzentriert auf eine Soccer-Kultur und sie versuchen, ihre Liga so schnell wie möglich auf die Strecke zu bringen. Die Liga ist 25 Jahre alt.
Du hast deinen ersten Versuch, aber es war etwas anderes als jetzt.
Hoffentlich werden wir in den nächsten 20-30 Jahren darüber reden und wirklich andere Liga-Komparisierungen für die Welt zeigen. Aber ich denke, die MLS ist auf die Liga-Komparisierungen konzentriert, die sie jetzt so gut und kompetent sind, wie sie können. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob europäische Liga-Komparisierungen in der MLS so interessiert sind. Aber Amerikaner lieben die MLS, die Bundesliga, die Liga. Man hat sich an ein europäisches Spiel gestritten. Ich denke, es werden konstante Komparisonen geschaffen. Aber die europäische Erinnerung wird immer für einen jungen Spieler da sein. Aber ich denke, dass die Liga seine Popularität auf der Bühne hat. Aber ich denke, es wird wie immer Zeit nehmen. Und ich denke, das Produkt jetzt ist viel besser als es vor fünf Jahren war. Und es wird weiter besser werden.
Aber wie kannst du diese Spieler, die jetzt, wenn sie in der MLS oder in Atlanta erfolgreich sind, andere Klubs oder andere Leakate haben? Wann denkst du, dass du zu dem Punkt reichst, wo du etwas aufgeben kannst, an das die Spieler sagen, ich bleibe hier?
Das ist ein gutes Punkt. Alphonso Davies zu Bayern München ist wahrscheinlich das größte. Deandre Jadlin hat in den Spurs, dann in den Newcastle. Es gibt jetzt viele junge Spieler, die in der MLS beginnen und sich in den Spurs bieten. Wir hoffen, dass unser Produkt, George Bello, in ein paar Jahren die Strecke von Alphonso Davies und jemandem hier zu bieten.
Man muss also alles verdienen.
Ich denke, die Liga wird das Geld verdienen, indem man so eine Verkaufsarbeit über die nächsten 5-10 Jahre macht. Aber jetzt sieht man, dass die Spieler, die 18, 19 Jahre alt sind, in den MLS-Kranken 10, 15, 20 Millionen Euro an Bidden bekommen. Und ein 21-Jähriger, ein 22-Jähriger, wie Miguel, der noch ein junger Spieler ist, wird wahrscheinlich für 20, 25 Millionen Euro mehr bezahlt. Ich denke, wenn wir eine Liga werden, die das tun kann, dann gibt es den jungen Spieler etwas Verständnis, um zu sagen, ich starte meine Karriere hier und habe wahrscheinlich eine bessere Chance, 1. Wenn wir ihnen eine Plattform für sie geben können, und es gibt eine Strecke, um in die Klubs in Europa zu gehen, dann ist das, was ich finde, wenn alles einen Spieler macht, der 17 ist und fragt, ob er nach Spanien, Deutschland, England gehen soll oder ob er hier bleiben soll für die nächsten drei oder vier Jahre. und 17-Jährigen. Das gibt ihnen Sicherheit und Zeit, sich zu entwickeln. Ich denke, wir müssen das als Klubs tun, um sicher zu sein, dass wir die Spieler entwickeln. Denn nach der Olympiade sind wir noch ein bisschen hinter, wenn es um die Entwicklung geht.
Wie denkst du über die Arbeit, die die FEDERATION hat? Die US Soccer Association.
Ich denke, dass es in der Moment separat gemacht wird, auf zwei anderen Seiten. Sie werden mehr zusammenarbeiten, als sie vorher haben. Aber ich denke, es gibt noch eine Coach-Education auf der MLS-Seite, noch eine Coach-Education auf der USSF-Seite. Ich denke, die MLS hat gerade gesagt, wir würden gerne in unsere Klubs investieren, in unsere Trainer, und sie haben sich nach jemanden gesucht, mit dem sie mit den Franzosen partnern wollen. Es ist jetzt viel mehr teurer, als Coach zu werden, aber die Theorie und die Methoden hinter den Verlusten sind viel besser.
Wie wichtig ist der Erfolg des US-Soccer-Teams für die MLS? Du hast viele hispanische Spieler, viele Spieler aus unterschiedlichen Hintergründen, aber du hast es im letzten Jahr mit der Missed World Cup gesehen. Was war der Einfluss auf das?
Ich denke, es ist sehr wichtig, dass das Nationale Team auf globaler Ebene gut macht, denn es gibt die Vertrauen der Länder, der Liga. Aber sie sind noch etwas separat, also hat das nicht den Einfluss auf die Liga, so hart wie es in anderen Ländern sein könnte. Aber das ist kein Entschluss. Wir haben da Arbeit zu tun. Hoffentlich wird die neue Generation, neue Trainer, neue Organisation, den Spiel an einem nationalen Team und an einem MLS-League-Level weiterverwenden.
Letzte Frage, zurück zum Tournament. Was denken Sie, werden die Spieler nach dieser Erfahrung am meisten erinnern?
Ich denke, sie werden die eigentliche Geschwindigkeit der Spielzeit verstehen, die außerhalb von ihrer Bubble ist, wo sie die besten Spieler sind. Wir spielen jetzt viel mehr mit den besten in Amerika, MLS vs. MLS. Es ist schwierig, aus dem Flugzeug zu kommen, sich umzudrehen und gegen diesen Level zu spielen.
Welchen Spieler sollte ich in der Zukunft aus dem Team ansehen? Nicht alle sagen. Warum sind sie nicht hier?
Sie sind mit dem ersten Team. George Bellow, Andrew Carlton und Chris Gosling. Oder eigentlich noch jünger. Aber wenn ich einen von diesen Jungen aus dem Team dieses Wochen mitbekommen werde, Jackson Conway, wir haben ihn gerade für einen Profisvertrag erzielt und wir haben hohe Hoffnung für ihn. Ich denke, diese beiden werden in der Zukunft junge Profis werden.
Vielen Dank. Soviel von Tony Annan von Atlanta United, der Academy Director, dort. Er ist auch auf Twitter aktiv als TonyAnnan1. Wenn ihr ihm noch Feedback zu dieser Folge geben wollt, es wird ihn vielleicht etwas unvermittelt treffen, dann könnt ihr das natürlich tun. Jetzt folgt ein Kurzausgespräch mit Michael Hartmann, Trainer der U19 von Hertha BSC. Das war der nächste, der mir für die Mikrofonflinte gelaufen ist. Mit ihm habe ich ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, über die Rolle eines Trainers, auch über die vielleicht negativen Seiten. Ich will es jetzt nicht überdramatisieren, aber als Trainer gerade im Nachwuchsfußball muss man auch viele negative Nachrichten überbringen. Ich habe versucht, darauf so ein bisschen einen Fokus zu legen. Ich bin gespannt, wie euch das Gespräch gefällt. Hertha BSC im letzten Jahr noch Turniersieger mit einem überragenden Arne Meyer. Da haben wir auch im damaligen Kurzpass länger darüber gesprochen. In diesem Jahr lief es nicht ganz so perfekt. Wussten wir zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme noch nicht, auf welchen Platz dann genau Hertha rauskäme. Aber hört doch mal rein, was er zu sagen hatte. Ich würde gerne ein bisschen grundsätzlich über Nachwuchsfußball sprechen. Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie zufällig das Sportgespräch im Deutschlandfunk mit Horst Rubisch gehört haben. Es gibt viele Diskussionen darüber, auch mit dem WM abschneiden. Was würden Sie sagen, sind die größten Herausforderungen, die Sie im Nachwuchsfußball zu bewältigen haben?
Die größten Herausforderungen sind immer, dass du jedes Jahr grundsätzlich mit neuen Charakteren zu tun hast. Du bekommst jedes Jahr wenigstens 10 bis 12 neue Spieler dazu. Dementsprechend musst du immer wieder eine neue Mannschaft formen. Du musst dich darauf einstellen, dass du nicht nur mit unterschiedlichen Charakteren, sondern auch, was Schule angeht, mit zu tun hast. Und dann natürlich die privaten Dinge, die die Jungs mit unterhaben. Und dann natürlich die Mischung zu finden. Weil in der U19 ist es meistens so, dass immer zwei Jahrgänge aufeinander treffen. Das ist auch immer nicht so einfach.
Das sind mitunter erstmal die größten Herausforderungen. Jetzt gibt es ja auch das Modell, dass man sagt, ein Trainer bleibt bei einem Jahrgang und wächst mit dem quasi mit. Was halten Sie davon? Was wären da die Vor- und Nachteile?
Ich habe beides schon mitgemacht. Ich bin schon in die U17 mit runter. Ich habe den U19-Jahrgang bei uns letztendlich drei Jahre trainiert. Der Vorteil ist, dass man als Trainer abrechnen kann. Ich sage mal, wie man die Spieler weiterentwickelt. Das ist immer auch für einen persönlich zu sehen. So schaffe ich einen Spieler, weiter zu bringen und oben ranzubringen. Wenn man einen Spieler nur ein Jahr hat, oder in der U19 hast du teilweise zwei Jahre, dann ist es sicherlich schwer, in einem Jahr die Impose so zu geben und ihn so weiter zu entwickeln, dass man sagen kann, der Hartmann hat so viel mitgegeben, der hat jetzt den Kick bekommen. Das ist der Unterschied, wenn man sagt, man geht mal mit. Andersrum muss man natürlich sagen, umso mehr Trainer die Jungs bekommen, umso mehr Reize bekommen sie natürlich auch. Jetzt geht es nur darum, wie schafft der Spieler diese Reize von dem Trainer und dem Trainer. Wie kriegt er das alles auf den Platz? Was nimmt er mit? Das ist auch immer wichtig. Aber da gehört auch ein bisschen Fußballintelligenz.
Jetzt haben Sie ja schon den 99er-Jahrgang genannt. Der 2000er-Jahrgang von Hertha ist ja auch schon berühmt, berüchtigt im positiven Sinne. Was macht denn die Hertha da anders, dass diese beiden Jahrgänge so stark sind? Oder ist das auch ein Zusammenkommen von bestimmten Talenten? Und dann reift das so besonders heran? Weil das haben Sie jetzt auch sehr viel in dem Profikader geschafft.
Das ist richtig, aber das fängt ja halt viel, viel früher an. Das heißt, dass wir natürlich gucken, dass wir im unteren Bereich, wir sprechen jetzt von 12, 13, die Jungs natürlich in Berlin zu uns holen, um dann natürlich durch unsere Trainer weiter zu formen. Und dementsprechend ist das eigentlich jetzt, wenn man sagt, klar, hast du mal einen Jahrgang, der ist etwas stärker, hast du mal einen Jahrgang, der ist etwas schwächer, aber nicht so trotzdem, wie immer, bestrebt, den ein oder anderen Spieler dort oben in den Profibereich zu bringen. Das ist in den letzten Jahren und jetzt natürlich auch bedingt mit dem 99er-Jahrgang sehr, sehr gut gelungen. Dementsprechend ist es aber auch wichtig, dass du einen Cheftrainer hast, der das natürlich auch will. Da haben wir sicherlich mit Pall ein Riesenglück, der letztendlich die Jungs Spieler dort mit einbaut. Ich glaube, das ist auch unser Weg, den wir gehen, weil wir nicht die Möglichkeit haben, irgendwelche teuren Spieler zu holen. Dementsprechend, wenn wir unsere Hausaufgaben mit dem unteren Bereich machen oder so, umso mehr haben dann der oberen Bereich davon leben kann.
Jetzt sieht man ja auch gerade, wenn man auf die aktuelle Hinrunde guckt, im Kader von Hertha gibt es eine Mischung aus Jung und Alt. Jetzt hat man aber auch vor allem in den letzten Spielen gesehen, das ist noch mal ein anderer Druck. So manche junge Spieler, da sind die Leistungsschwankungen naturgemäß noch ein bisschen größer als bei den erfahrenen Spielern. Gibt es denn eigentlich irgendeine Möglichkeit, die Spieler auf solche Situationen vorzubereiten, oder geht das tatsächlich nur, indem sie es tun?
Das ist immer dann das Trainer, sein Trainers Handwerk, dann zu erkennen, wann braucht der Junge vielleicht mal eine Pause, oder wann muss ich mit dem mal reden?
Gut, aber wenn man viele Verletzte hat, dann gibt es ja nicht eine Pause.
Ja, das ist ja richtig, aber es ist halt trotzdem so, dass du aufpassen musst, dass du nicht irgendwelche Spieler verbrennst. Klar, wenn jetzt aufgrund von Verletzten oder so, hast du keine andere Wahl, aber dann ist es eben halt so. Aber auch da muss der Spieler letztendlich daraus lernen. Und klar versuchen wir, gerade jetzt im U17- und U19-Bereich, die Jungs auch ein bisschen darauf vorzubereiten, was kann eigentlich alles passieren im Profibereich. Und nicht, dass sie nachher, ist egal, ob sie mal, jetzt bin ich mal drinnen, dann bin ich mal draußen, dann bin ich mal auf der Bühne, dann bin ich gar nicht dabei und alles oder so, sondern sie müssen lernen, damit umzugehen. Und das ist halt schon wichtig.
Wie viele Spieler mussten Sie denn in Ihrer Karriere jetzt schon sagen, es tut mir leid, aber leider wird das zumindest hier bei uns nicht funktionieren? Viel mal Daumen.
Es gibt sehr, sehr viele. Aber ich sage immer zu jedem Spieler, weil es wäre nicht alle bei Hertha BSC den Sprung in die Bundesliga schaffen, aber es gibt halt immer irgendwo auch einen zweiten Weg, wo man halt über Umwege, hobs über die Regionalliga, hobs über die dritte Liga gehen kann und dann auf einmal, zack, wirst du dann mal da gesehen, wirst du dann mal da gesehen und dann kann es durchaus passieren, dass man dann trotzdem über Umwege den Sprung doch schafft. Deshalb sage ich halt nie zu jedem Spieler, du wirst das nie schaffen. Ich bin mir zu 100 Prozent sicher.
Aber das kam auch schon vor? Dass sie sich zu 100 Prozent sicher waren, die mal gesagt haben, sorry, aber das wird leider nicht gehen?
Ja, ich glaube, dann wäre ich halt schon kein guter Trainer, wenn ich das nicht erkennen würde. Wer könnte das schaffen? Klar, in dem bezahlten Fußball kann es fast jeder schaffen. Aber jetzt ist die Frage, reicht Regionalliga aus? Oder selbst in der Oberliga kann man schon ein bisschen Geld verdienen. Aber die Jungs wollen ja alle irgendwo weiter. Und deshalb versuche ich denen natürlich nicht, wenn ich jetzt auch in die Gespräche gehe, nicht zu sagen, das wird nichts, sondern ich versuche halt letztendlich, das ein bisschen diplomatischer zu machen.
Jetzt haben Sie ja dann so eine komische Twitter-Funktion als Jugend-Coach. Sie sind so ein bisschen Vater, ein bisschen Lehrer, auf jeden Fall viel, viel Trainer, müssen aber wahrscheinlich in vielen Lebensbereichen auch immer mal wieder mit Rat und Tat zur Seite stehen. Verfolgt man dann manchmal weiter, was aus Spielern geworden ist, die es bei einem selbst nicht geschafft haben, oder muss man sich davon lösen, um sich auf die alltäglichen Aufgaben zu konzentrieren? Googeln Sie manchmal noch ehemalige Schützlinge?
Na ja, googeln, ich sage mal so, ich lese ja auch Zeitung. Man weiß ja schon natürlich, gerade bei den Spielern, wo man weiß, die hatten eine gute Einstellung, die haben dort versucht, nach oben reinzukommen. Und wenn es der eine oder andere mal schafft, dritte, zweite Liga oder so, klar, gucke ich, was machen die, spielen die, spielen die, wie viel, da komme ich schon nach. Das hat aber nichts damit zu tun, dass es jetzt für mich ein riesen Zeitaufwand ist. Sondern das ist einfach so ein bisschen Lektüre, wo man einfach mal nachschaut. Also das mache ich schon.
Gibt es da auch manchmal noch Kontakt?
Ja, ich sage mal gerade so, ob wir jetzt oder wie letztes Jahr eben auch die Deutsche Mannschaft, dann kommt schon mal noch die eine oder andere Nachricht oder so, Glückwunsch Trainer und alles. Gut, nun habe ich natürlich auch jetzt auch bei Hertha, da sind ja auf Grund viele Spieler oben mit dabei oder so, zu dem man halt auch jeden Tag eigentlich so mehr oder weniger so Kontakt hat und fragt, wie geht es, wie ist ich fast oder so, aber selbst aus meiner Zeit in Rostock, wo ich 2010 Deutscher Meister geworden bin, selbst da gibt es noch zwei, drei oder so, wo man mal, ich will nicht sagen sich regelmäßig, aber so zwei bis drei Mal im Jahr einfach mal eine Nachricht schreibt.
Schön. Jetzt gibt es ja verschiedene Ansätze, wie man so Jugendfußball innerhalb eines Vereins aufziehen kann und so mit der Goldstandard gilt ja immer La Masia von Barcelona und die Art und Weise, wie die es da tun, hat ja vor allem damit zu tun, dass sie die Spieler von Anfang an an eine Spielweise gewöhnen und quasi die Spielweise und das Spielsystem sich nicht verändert, nur die Spieler, die die Akademie durchlaufen. Wie machen sie denn das bei Hertha BSC?
Naja, es ist halt so klar, haben wir eine gewisse Spielphilosophie, die haben wir, aber die ist halt sehr offen in allen Richtungen. Das heißt oder so, ich bin halt ein Freund davon, letztendlich den Jungs immer viel mitzugeben, weil sie halt auch in ihrem Leben, sie werden halt nicht immer nur bei Hertha BSC spielen. Es wird halt auch mal ein anderer Trainer da sein und sie werden halt auch mal den Verein wechseln. Und dann kann der Trainer kommen und der Trainer kommen. Und wenn du dann aber nur, ich sag mal, in eine Richtung geschult wurdest, dann bringt das dir nichts weiter. Sondern da finde ich halt schon, ob du dann eine Viererkette spielst, ob du eine Dreierkette spielst, ob du mit zwei Stürmern, ob du mit drei Stürmern spielst oder so. Das kann nie verkehrt sein, wenn man viele Dinge mitbekommt. Jetzt geht es halt nur darum oder so. Es gibt, wie im normalen Leben, es gibt intelligente Fußballer und es gibt natürlich auch, die nicht so intelligent sind. Die eben halt letztendlich, wo man immer wieder Hinweise geben muss, damit sie es verstehen oder so. Und dementsprechend finde ich, kann das nicht verkehrt sein, wenn du eben halt viele Dinge mitbekommst.
Aber das heißt, so eine richtig einheitliche Philosophie, die über allem steht, außer so gewisse Prinzipien, die man wahrscheinlich hat, gibt es jetzt bei Hertha BSC nicht?
Na ja, jetzt hängt es ja mal davon ab, was jetzt letztendlich genau, klar haben wir bestimmte Richtungen vorzuweisen, dass wir mit unserer Mannschaft immer versuchen, sehr dominant zu spielen. Aber vom System her sind wir total frei. Und wir unterhalten uns halt schon, deshalb finden ja auch regelmäßig Trainersitzungen statt. Was können wir verbessern, wo müssen wir ansetzen? Und daraus ziehen wir dann immer. Und dann machen wir letztendlich so einen kleinen Pool draus und dann sagen wir, ok, jetzt haben wir da und da die Schwerpunkte gesetzt. Aber ich finde letztendlich wichtig, ist halt immer der Austausch unter den Trainern selber. Weil dann kannst du eben schon herausgehen, pass auf, der und der Spieler oder so. Oder wir machen das so. Und was können wir vielleicht anders machen? Und das finde ich halt immer so, ist dieser Austausch schon sehr, sehr wichtig.
Und wer gibt da dann die Linie vor?
Der Verein, der sportliche Leitung.
Jetzt würde mich noch ein Themenkomplex interessieren, weil es ja auch eine Debatte war, ob es in Deutschland zu wenige deutsche, in Deutschland ausgebildete Spieler gibt, die mal ins Dribbling gehen, Dribbling gewinnen, die ein hohes Tempo aufs Feld bringen. Was ja so ein bisschen die grundsätzliche Frage ist, bilden wir eher gruppentaktisch aus oder individuell taktisch? Wo stehen Sie da? Kann man das überhaupt so voneinander trennen?
Die Diskussion, die kenne ich, klar. Aber es hängt ja viel davon ab, dass du in erster Linie erstmal in der Trainerausbildung anfängst. Weil du musst ja da letztendlich, da sind ja dann die Trainer, die gewisse Dinge dann nachher umsetzen.
Was ja dann heißen würde, dass in der Trainerausbildung ein bisschen zu einseitig vielleicht auf gruppentaktische Elemente gesetzt wurde und die Individualität nicht so richtig gefördert wurde an einen Stellen?
Na ja, wenn du halt in der U13 anfängst, klar, wo du auf Großfeld gehst und du meinst, wir müssen jetzt in irgendwelche Systemen spielen, dann kann es schon mal sein. Das hängt aber immer von dem Trainertypen her ab. Das ist halt nun mal so, dass junge Trainer relativ schnell nach oben wollen. Und wie komme ich nach oben? Wenn ich natürlich immer gucke, ich habe ein gutes System, ich spiele ergebnisorientiert und vergesse aber letztendlich die individuelle Ausbildung. Das heißt, wenn ich immer einen Spieler sage, er soll den beiden nach rechts spielen oder er soll im Prinzip diagonal, dann helfe ich dem Spieler damit nicht. Sondern ein Spieler muss ja auf dem Spielfeld Lösungen für sich selber finden. Wenn ich ihm aber immer wieder sage, du musst das und das machen, dann hat er nur dieses Schema drin und dann wird er sich nicht entwickeln. Deshalb meine ich oder so, es hängt immer von dem jeweiligen Trainer herab. Wenn ich das natürlich immer wieder einfordere im Training, du sollst ins 1 gegen 1 gehen oder so, dann wird er sich halt auch verbessern. Wenn ich aber immer sage, pass auf, du musst jetzt abspielen, dann wird er sich zwar schon weiter entwickeln, aber er wird nicht in diese 1 gegen 1 Duelle gehen. Und das ist letztendlich wichtig. Ich muss ja auf dem Spielfeld eine Entscheidung treffen. Und die Entscheidung kann ich den Spieler aber nicht abnehmen. Sondern die muss er selber. Und dann kommt es damit so, was sehe ich um mich herum? Weil ich von draußen sehe natürlich schon viel und kann sagen, warum hat er den Ball jetzt nicht dahin gespielt? Aber erkennt es der Spieler, sieht der Spieler, dass er den Ball dahin spielt? Oder sieht er das gar nicht? Weil es halt sehr schnell geht. Und das ist letztendlich dann nachher das, was du immer versuchst, oder jedenfalls mache ich das so, in den Trainingsspielen immer wieder versuchen zu fördern. Aber deshalb komme ich wieder darauf zurück, wenn wir da in der Ausbildung, klar musst du diese Systeme, musst du das Taktische, musst du wie kann ich pressen und alles, klar musst du das durchgehen, aber trotzdem wirst du das andere nicht mal nachlesen.
Ist das dann auch der Reiz, den so ein Hallenturnier ausmacht, weil da die Geschwindigkeit noch mal nicht so hoch ist und man eigentlich immer in direkten Duellen ist und sich da dann durchsetzen muss, entweder über den Pass oder eben auch mal im Dribbling?
Genau, das ist halt letztendlich, weil wir hatten uns vorhin gerade darüber unterhalten, warum mit der Regel oder so, dass der Torwart zum Beispiel den Ball über die Mittellinie abwerfen kann. Ich finde das gut, weil einfach mehr Raum da ist. Es ist auch nicht so viel Taktik, sondern du musst es zielen. Und dann letztendlich klar, wenn derjenige dann den Ball bekommt, kann er sich im 1 gegen 1 durchsetzen. Oder er sieht oder so, dass vielleicht einer mitläuft, den ich im Prinzip mitnehmen kann, der den Abschuss suchen kann. Und deshalb sollte man das halt auch immer wieder forcieren.
Okay, letzte Frage. Bisschen gemeine Frage. Eine, eine allerletzte und das andere war der letzte Themenkomplex. Auf welche ihre Spiele muss ich ganz genau ein Auge haben, weil die werden mir noch viel Freude machen. Sie dürfen nicht sagen, alle. Sie dürfen nicht sagen, ihr fällt ihnen jetzt keiner ein.
Das ist jetzt die, die wir jetzt dabei haben. Wir haben jetzt den Dennis Jastremski, der sicherlich oben schon mal dabei war. Der kommt sicherlich jetzt am Anfang der Saison ein bisschen weniger zum Einsatz. Aber der ist schon mal sehr nah dran. Und dann hast du sicherlich, der jetzt nicht mit dabei ist, der Oma-Rikik, das ist der Bruder vom Karim-Rikik, der bei uns Endverteidiger und Kapitän ist. Der hat sicherlich gute Voraussetzungen. Und dann hast du immer noch ein, zwei Spieler, wo du sagst, na mal gucken, da bin ich gespannt, wo der Weg hin geht.
Die wollen es aber noch nicht verraten.
Du hast halt mit dem Julian Eibricht, mit dem Jonas-Michel-Bringt, du hast selbst Ben-Jessek Nankam, der jetzt hier unser Kapitän ist. Da musst du gerade bei so einem Spieler stehen. Und dann kann er sich sicherlich entwickeln. Ich glaube, man muss gucken. Ich will mich da nicht direkt festlegen, ob man es schafft oder nicht. Aber klar ist, man sollte da ein Auge drauf werfen.
Ich könnte noch ewig weiterreden, aber jetzt war es das wirklich. Das war Michael Hartmann, Trainer der U19 von Hertha BSC. Neben ihm stand Nico Willig, Trainer der U19 des VfB Stuttgart. Der hat dann schon gesagt, bei dir setze ich mich lieber hin. Ich habe gesehen, das dauert bei dir länger, wenn du deine berühmte letzte Frage stellst und es dann vielleicht dann doch nur die vorletzte ist. Er hat das sehr mit Humor genommen. Ich fand, dass wir ein interessantes Gespräch geführt haben. Ich hätte es gerne noch weitergeführt, aber irgendwann muss man dann auch wirklich die Trainer auch mal in Ruhe lassen. Es war toll, wie viel Zeit sie sich genommen haben und dass sie auch wirklich auf jede Frage geantwortet haben. Das habe ich noch gar nicht gesagt, aber ihr habt es ja inzwischen schon gehört. Die Gespräche sind komplett ungeschnitten, so wie wir es im Rasenfunk immer machen. Dementsprechend sind dann auch noch einige grammatikalische Fehler von mir drin im englischsprachigen Teil. Und auch viel mehr Amps als sonst gewohnt. Es war auch für mich eine neue Situation. Da muss der Max noch lernen, auch mit seinem Equipment ein bisschen anders umzugehen. Aber es ist ja alles hier Learning by Doing im Podcast-Bereich. Jetzt hört ihr eben das Gespräch mit Nico Willig, der auch sehr, sehr interessante Thesen hatte. Mit dem hätte ich gerne, so wie mit allen anderen beiden auch, noch ein bisschen länger gesprochen. Vielleicht ist das ja an einer späteren Stelle mal möglich. Hört einfach mal selber rein. Ich bin gespannt, wie es euch gefällt. Würde ich gerne noch zwei, drei Fragen stellen? Ja, das ist ein Podcast. Bei dem hat man unendlich viel Zeit. Sie signalisieren einfach, wenn es ihnen genug ist. Es gibt ja viele Diskussionen drüber. Da hat jetzt Horst Rubisch, hat sich in die Richtung geäußert. Lukas Kwasniok, den Sie bestimmt auch kennen, hat auch ähnlich gesprochen. Zur Diskussion, wie viel soll man eigentlich jungen Spielern abnehmen? Nicht nur, was den Fußball angeht, sondern auch sonst im Leben. Wie sehr soll man sie pampern? Wie versuchen Sie denn da, den richtigen Mittelweg zu finden? Zwischen Altmodus, hätte man jetzt gesagt, fördern und fordern.
Ich glaube, man muss den Spieler nicht nur als Spieler bezeichnen, sondern als ein Mensch, der talentiert ist im Bereich Fußball. Der Mensch muss gewisse Hürden überspringen im Alltag. Der muss genauso im Fußball gewisse Hürden überspringen. Man muss ihnen diese Hürden nicht alle abbauen. Aber man kann ihnen auch nicht nur Hürden aufstellen, sondern sagen, sie tun zu wenig. Diese jungen Spieler betreiben schon extremen Aufwand, leben in einem extremen Druckumfeld. Mit Beratern, Schule, Nationalmannschaften, Lehrgängen, was auch immer. Die bringen für 16, 17, 18-Jährige schon enorme Leistungen und haben enorme Wochenabläufe. Da muss man ihnen manchmal auch Sachen vereinfachen und muss ihnen manchmal auch Freiräume schaffen, wo sie einfach auch mal wegschalten können von diesem Druck und diesem Fußball. Es ist schon eine Mischung. Man darf sie nicht nur pudern, das tut keinem gut. Wenn man diesen Menschen ehrlich begegnet und in einen Austausch kommt und die das Gefühl haben, der interessiert sich für mich und es geht ihm nicht nur um den Erfolg des Vereins, des Trainers, sondern es geht ihm um ihn, um die Entwicklung, dann kriegt er mit jedem Spieler einen ganz guten Dialog hin. Dann ist er nicht nur Spieler, sondern auch Mensch. Dann funktioniert das und dann hilft das auch, um ein besserer Fußballer zu werden. Der Mensch entwickelt sich dann in seinem Charakter.
Und reden da heutzutage mehr Parteien mit, als es vielleicht noch vor 10, 15 Jahren der Fall war?
Ich glaube schon, dass mehr Parteien mitreden, aber auch wesentlich schneller mitreden. Es hängen schon viele an dem Thema Fußball. Es ist wesentlich mehr Geld und mehr Hektik im Geschäft, als es vor 10 Jahren war. Von daher steckt das auch die jungen Leute an. Wir haben noch weniger Zeit, um Freiräume zu gestalten. Von daher ist es bestimmt schwieriger geworden.
Welche Rolle spielen da die sozialen Netzwerke? Ich stelle mir vor, dass es manchmal gar nicht so einfach ist, weil man selbst noch in einer anderen Welt groß geworden ist. Da würde ich mich jetzt selber auch mit einbeziehen. Aber wenn ich mir angucke, welche Instagram-Profile zum Teil schon U13, U14, U15-Spiele haben, zum Teil schon absurd viele Follower-Zahlen, da frage ich mich, wie kann man die da in einen gesunden Umgang mit schicken? Weil einem ja selber auch die Lebensrealität dazu fehlt. Also ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, wie das wäre, mit 15 vor so vielen Leuten meine Instagram-Stories zu teilen.
Ich hab neulich einen Vortrag über dieses Thema gehört, aber wir hatten das bei VfB als Thema und hatten dann hochrangige Referenten dazu. Es fehlt da Begriff gerade dazu, den ich sagen will. Es ist einfach auch eine andere Definition des Lebens, des Menschseins, der Darstellung. Und die sind so aufgewachsen, die haben das nur so erlebt, dass das wichtig ist und deswegen versuchen sie, das zu kopieren. Und ich glaube, wir können das nicht verhindern. Wir dürfen es auf gar keinen Fall irgendwie limitieren, weil dann wird es noch attraktiver.
Auch nicht mit so Regeln wie in der Kabine soll es nicht stattfinden?
Limitieren oder verbieten, wenn das mal so. Aber ich glaube, man muss ihnen ein Bewusstsein schaffen, dass es auch noch eine Welt außerhalb von Instagram-Profilen und Bildern gibt und dass einfach eine Kommunikation zwischen Menschen viel mehr Spaß macht und viel lustiger ist, als irgendwelche Dinge zu posten und jemand postet noch was dazu. Also ich glaube, wenn man das schafft, eine Gruppe so zu entwickeln, dass ihr auch mal das Ding weglegt und gemeinsam ins Lachen kommt, dann ist normale Grubbendynamik entwickelt. Und Grubbendynamik ist Mannschaftssport. Und Mannschaftssport ist halt dieser Fußball immer noch.
Hört sich jetzt aber schon mehr nach Pädagogik als Fußball-Trainer an?
Ich habe auf jeden Fall auch eine pädagogische Ader. Ich glaube, in mir gehört dazu. Ich glaube, das muss man haben, weil wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, dieses Spannungsfeld ist total brutal, glaube ich, in dem die sich bewegen. Und wir können da die Taktik bis ins allerletzte tiefste Detail machen. Aber wenn der Mensch sich nicht entwickelt, oder die Persönlichkeit der Spieler, der Menschen sich da nicht entwickelt, dann bringt die taktische Perfektion nichts. Weil dann die Basis dafür fehlt. Fürs selbstständiges Handeln, für zu wissen, wie Mannschaftssport funktioniert, wie die Mitspieler ticken.
Ich habe vorhin die Frage schon beim Kollegen gestellt, wie viele Spiele mussten Sie schon grob über den Daumen gepeilt sagen? Beim VfB Stuttgart wird es für dich leider nicht weitergehen.
Keiner einzigen, weil das bei uns die Aufgabe nicht vom Trainer ist, sondern von der sportlichen Leitung. Meine Beurteilung ist nicht abschließend, sondern die letzten Entscheidungen trifft eine sportliche Leitung. Von daher sind diese brutalen Abschlussgespräche nicht mein Job. Trotzdem muss ich tagtäglich Entscheidungen treffen. Ich weiß auch, dass sie für die Jungs hart sind. Sie tragen auch gewisse Konsequenzen. Auch da ist es wieder, man muss es ihnen erklären. Man muss sie zur Seite nehmen. Man muss ihnen im Raum lassen zu sprechen. Man muss selber das zu begründen. Man muss ihnen in die Augen gucken und dabei sagen, das ist meine Meinung dazu. Du spielst jetzt dieses Spiel nicht. Du hast seit 3 Wochen auch nicht gespielt. Das tut weh, weil du mit einem jungen Mann weh tust. Aber das gehört eben dazu. Das haben sie sich ausgesucht. So ist es zukünftig in ihrem Berufsleben, wo auch immer sie landen, wird sie das immer wieder treffen. Genauso im Profibereich. Das gehört dazu, mit so etwas umzugehen und daraus Energie zu schöpfen. Wir Jugendtrainer sind oft die ersten, die sich mit so etwas konfrontieren. Das ist vielleicht auch das harte Los von uns.
Aber ist es nicht ein bisschen komisch, dass Sie als häufiger zu sehende Bezugsperson, als die sportliche Leitung, bei solchen Gesprächen gar nicht mit dabei sind? Sie haben ja auch eine persönliche Beziehung zu den Nachwuchsfußballern.
Ich bin dann nicht dabei. Das findet auch zwischen Beratern, Eltern und Spielern oft statt. Aber natürlich hat man über die Saison gesehen, dass es nicht überraschend ist, was dann kommt. Es entwickelt sich durch den Dialog und die Entwicklung zwischen Trainer und Spieler natürlich schon auch ein Gefühl für diese Richtung. Das abschließende Gespräch für deine sportliche Leitung.
Das ergibt natürlich so dann Sinn. Jetzt haben wir ja so ein bisschen die Diskussion in Deutschland gehabt. Natürlich auch, wegen WM-Ausscheiden. Alles ganz fürchterlich. Der deutsche Fußball liegt da nieder. Wir hätten so wenige individuell starke Spieler, die auch mal ein Risiko in Kauf nehmen würden. Jetzt frage ich mich, wie soll man Risiko mit Ergebnissen unter einen Hut bringen? Das ist im Profifußball schon fast unmöglich. Deswegen spielen die meisten Mannschaften in der Liga eher ein Risiko vermeidenden Fußball oder versuchen, wenn dann den Gegner zu Fehlern zu zwingen und eigene Fehler zu vermeiden. Wie ist es im Nachwuchsfußball? Genießen Sie da noch mehr Freiheiten? Wie versuchen Sie, diesen Spagat herzubekommen?
Ich glaube, dass man auch sagen muss, dass die Länder wie Frankreich oder auch andere Nationen wie England bezüglich Risiko, auch Spieler haben, die wesentlich mehr ins Risiko gehen. Warum ist das so? Weil unser Leben natürlich auch total stark von Schule geprägt ist und wir die Spieler zwingen, Schulabschlüsse zu machen, damit sie nicht zu viel Risiko gehen und auf der Straße stehen. Ich glaube, in Frankreich und England gibt es so eine starke Unterschicht, die alles auf die Karte Fußball setzt. Und damit kommen auch Spieler raus, wir sehen tolle Spieler, die von ganz unten nach oben kommen, aber da bleiben auch ganz viele auf der Strecke. Weil die einfach total alles riskieren und bei uns wird nicht alles riskiert. Und dort haben die mit 15 keine Schule mehr. Und probieren es nur noch mit Fußball ganz oft. Deswegen ist das vielleicht auch die deutsche Gesellschaft, die das ein bisschen abbremst und dann fehlen uns diese Risikotypen, die wir jetzt da als Topspieler sehen. Aber wir haben federnd damit unsere Menschen und unsere Persönlichkeiten schon ein bisschen besser ab, die dann im Leben anderweitig untergebracht werden als in den anderen Ländern, die dann einfach nichts haben und dem Fußball auch nicht unterkommen. Das Grundlegend ist, glaube ich, schon so für allgemein gesprochen. Für uns jetzt, für mich als Trainer meiner Mannschaft, es ist immer eine Risikoabwägung, die ein Spieler treffen muss. Er muss Entscheidungen treffen. Entscheidungen sollen mutig sein. Mutig gehört zu dribbeln. Wir haben heute eine Situation, in der wir einen riesen Konter fahren und mein Spieler ins Dribbling geht. Und er verliert dieses Dribbling. Wenn er es gewinnt, steht er blank. Und er verliert, und wir kriegen mit einem Pass später ein Gegentor. Dann kann man traurig sein drüber, das sind wir, aber man kann ihn deswegen nicht an die Wand klatschen, weil er kurz einen Spieler nur noch davor war, um einen Führungstreffer zu erziehen. Das gehört dazu, man muss es einfordern, nur so gelingt es. Dann muss man aber auch, wenn es mal schief geht, darf man nicht auf sie einklopfen, sondern da muss man einfach genauso neutral damit umgehen.
Als Trainer kann man sich dann natürlich zwingen, nicht immer darauf reinzuklopfen, und das lernt man ja auch wahrscheinlich, man hat ja ein sehr gutes Gefühl für die eigenen Spieler. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass aber auch in der Öffentlichwahrnehmung vom Nachwuchsfußball inzwischen auch schon jetzt nicht gleich Bundesligamarstelle beangelegt werden, aber es ist für Fans schon sehr wichtig, ob dann die Junior in der Bundesliga gut mit dabei sind, ob man mal eine Meisterschaft gewonnen hat. Wie kann man es denn schaffen, diesen Druck wegzuhalten von den Spielern oder ist das wichtig, weil es sie auch vorbereitet auf das Profitum?
Es gibt Grenzen. Ich glaube, man darf nicht alles auf die Karte Ergebnis ersetzen. Und trotzdem ist das Ergebnis ja eigentlich nur ein Produkt. Wenn man über Saison ein sehr, sehr gutes Produkt abliefert als Trainer, als Mannschaft, als Spieler, dann entsteht Entwicklung. Und Entwicklung mündet über kurz oder lang in einem Ergebnis. Und das Ziel muss sein, dieses Produkt so gut zu machen, diesen einzelnen Spielern und die Gruppe, dass diese Räten ineinandergreifen. Und dann entsteht dieses Ergebnis. Aber nur wegen einem Spiel alles in Frage zu stellen und gewisse klassische Profifußballmechanismen auszulösen, das geht im Jugendbereich nicht. Trotzdem sieht man bei Jugendmannschaften, die einfach eine gute Entwicklung haben, schlägt sich das in der Tabelle nieder. Plus, minus ein Spiel, plus, minus ein, zwei Spiele. Ob das jetzt dritter oder fünfter ist, ist ja nicht die Rolle. Wer sich entwickelt wird, aber nicht zwölfter von 14 Mannschaften. Das ist so meine Meinung. Deswegen, ich finde, die Mischung macht schon, man braucht beides, weil später braucht man es eben auch. Daher gehört das Ergebnis dazu und die Tabelle ist wichtig.
Und wenn sich jetzt die Mannschaft entwickelt, wie entwickelt sich denn die Liga? Wir haben jetzt gerade eine Bundesliga, sehen wir ja gerade, da hat sich schon vom spielerischen Hau her ein bisschen verändert. Wir haben jetzt wieder mehr Ballbesitzteams und auch mit zum Teil anderen Systemen. Ist es im Nachwuchsfußball eigentlich ähnlich, dass sich da von einer Saison zu anderen hin peu à peu das immer weiter, weiter entwickelt und man auch die eigene Mannschaft neu ausrichten muss?
Ich glaube, dass im Nachwuchsfußball total viel passiert, weil es ja im Endeffekt auch die Plattform der Trainer ist, sich ein bisschen auszuprobieren. Also die vielen NNZ-Trainer, die oben jetzt sind, die konnten sich da ausprobieren. Und ausprobieren heißt, Dinge mutig anzupacken, zu tun und dann zu schauen, was passiert draus. Ich glaube, das ist ein Kohfeldt, ein Sandro Schwarz, ein Julian, ein Dome, die haben da alle viel ausprobiert. Und die haben auch mal Sachen und Spiele vielleicht auch mal versenkt und falsch ausprobiert. Das gehört dazu. Und das ist das gleiche Risiko, das ein Spieler geht. Braucht vielleicht auch ein Trainer in seiner Entwicklung. Deswegen glaube ich, A-Jungfußball ist auch ein Versuchsfeld.
Und was probieren Sie da aus?
Ich habe zum Beispiel in der Saison zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben auf Dreierkette umgestellt. Ich hatte einfach das Gefühl, es sitzt Zeit dazu, es passt total gut zu den Spielern. Und dann habe ich gesagt, jetzt musst du dich als Trainer flexibel umstellen, nicht in deinem Lieblingssystem festhalten, sondern jetzt stellen wir das um. Und innerhalb kurzer Zeit es ihnen zu vermitteln, das war dann die Kunst und die Überzeugung zu schaffen. Und wenn man jetzt die Tabelle anguckt und die Spiele und die Art und Weise, wie wir spielen, dann hat das glaube ich ganz gut funktioniert. Und auf einmal haben wir etwas Neues entwickelt. Ich kann aber jetzt nicht mit Sicherheit sagen, dass wir das bis zum Saisonende machen, wenn ich im März das Gefühl habe, da könnte mal wieder was anderes stattfinden, dann müssen wir vielleicht wieder was anderes stattfinden. Das gehört auch dazu.
Was war denn das Lieblingssystem?
Wir haben vor eineinhalb Jahren 4-2-2-2 gespielt.
Oh, in der Hoffenheimer-Variante mit Flach, Flach, Flach?
Ja, in der Hoffenheimer-Variante, aber auch in der Leipziger-Variante.
Entschuldigung, ich meinte Leipzig.
Also Leipziger-Variante. Wir haben uns da auch ein bisschen was abgeschaut, sicherlich. Wir haben uns dann aber auch jetzt ein bisschen umumstellen müssen, weil es einfach besser zu den Spielern gepasst hat. Und das gehört auch dazu.
Jetzt beruht ja so ein System, gerade bei Leipzig beruht ja darauf, den Gegner so sehr unter Druck zu setzen in bestimmten Zonen des Feldes, dass der Ballverlust sehr wahrscheinlich ist und der Weg zum Tor dann auch relativ kurz. Ist es denn einfacher, einen Ballverlust zu provozieren im Nachwuchsfußball?
Bei uns war es so, dass wir beim VfB schon den Ball sehr stark im Mittelpunkt haben und den eigenen Ball besitzen konnten. Das ist das Paradoxe, die Leipziger Grundordnung, aber die hat bei uns bewirkt, dass wir dadurch vier zentrale Mittelfeldspieler hatten. Damit konnten wir einfach noch eine höhere Zentrumsdominanz im eigenen Ballbesitz entwickeln. Das hat sich dadurch total positiv entwickelt.
Standen die dann im Korridor oder standen die diagonal für die Passwinkel?
Zwei, zwei, zwei, die standen da und dann mit den Spitzen. Damit konnten sie richtig schön... Klar, da hast du dann noch die zwei Spitzen, die tief, und dann hast du Dreieckbildungen dadurch, die, wenn du es dann leicht verschiebst, aber nicht grundsätzlich die Raute. Und so konnten wir dann relativ viele Situationen außen-innen schaffen mit Positionswechseln. Wir haben dann auch Gegenfuß gespielt, also zum Beispiel der rechte Zehner war einfach ein Linksfuß, der sich etwas breiter freimacht, dann innen reinzieht und so. Das sind so Dinge, die wir dann geschaffen haben und es war schwierig für den Gegner Zuordnungen zu finden. Er hatte ja auch nie vier zentrale Mittelfeldspieler. Jetzt weiß ich aber den Ausgangspunkt der Frage nicht mehr.
Ich habe gefragt, ob es schwieriger ist, genau. Oder ist es schwieriger, das Pressing einzuüben? Ich habe beides noch nicht gemacht, ich bin leider kein professioneller Fußballspieler.
Nein, aber Balleroberung, Ballgewinn gehört dazu. Und ob das jetzt mannschaftstaktisch ist, das muss nicht immer mannschaftstaktisch sein, weil im Endeffekt geht es um die Qualität eines Spielers, um eine Spelle zu erobern und Momente zu erkennen, wann er losgehen kann, um Pässe abzufangen, wann er losgehen kann, in einen Zweikampf zu kommen. Und das muss man, glaube ich, bei Ihnen schulen. Und das gehört genauso dazu unten wie oben.
Aber Sie würden jetzt nicht sagen, bei Jugendfußballern, also beim Gegner dann, die ja mit diesem Stress auch umgehen müssen, ist es wahrscheinlicher, dass das zum Ball Verlust führt, weil sie so eine Situation ja auch noch gar nicht so häufig erlebt haben, jetzt gerade gegen so ein wildes 4-2-2-2.
Ja, wenn es der Gegner nicht gewöhnt ist, dann tut er sich sicherlich dann schwer. Dann ist es schon ein Vorteil. Andererseits, wie jedes System auch da, seine Schwächen, wenn er nicht analysiert hat, dann kann er auch wieder Mittel dagegen finden. Von dem her, das war phasenweise leichter, das war aber auch manchmal schwerer. Das ist schon ein schwieriges Ball zu betreiben.
Okay, ich habe hier schon eine 5-Minuten-Warnung gekommen, deswegen habe ich jetzt eine letzte Frage. Welche Spieler in Ihrer Mannschaft soll ich im Auge behalten? Sie dürfen nicht sagen, alle. Das lasse ich nicht durchgehen.
Im Auge behalten? Ja, ich glaube, dass es schon Spieler bei uns gibt, wir haben Nationalspieler, die sind schon in dem Auge, würde ich jetzt einmal sagen. Ich glaube, es gibt schon Spieler wie Nick Betzner oder Kevin Grimm, Alexander Kopf, die momentan nicht ganz als Top-Spieler in ihrem Jahrgang behandelt werden und die trotzdem aufgrund ihrer Körperlichkeit noch nicht so endgültig entwickelt sind und die da noch Schritte machen werden, weil sie einfach fleißige, kluge und technisch sehr gute Spieler sind. Ich glaube, dass wir die nächsten Jahre schon noch ein paar Schritte gehen können und vielleicht noch ein oder zwei noch mehr in die Öffentlichkeit.
Genau die werde ich jetzt im Auge überhalten. Soweit Nico Willig, Trainer der U19 des VfB Stuttgart. Das waren die drei Gespräche, die ich führen konnte im Rahmen dieser Mixed Zone. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine andere Folge als sonst. Ich habe versucht, ins Detail reinzugehen, aber logischerweise kann man dennoch nur an der Oberfläche kratzen. Ich fand dennoch alle drei Gespräche für sich genommen hatten interessante Aspekte, auch unterschiedliche Aspekte. Mir hat das besonders gut gefallen. Ich hoffe, bei euch kommt es ebenso auf Anklang. Gebt gerne Feedback unter mitmachen.rasen.de. Das ist auch nicht die einzige Kurzpass-Folge, die ich vor Ort in Sindelfingen aufgezeichnet habe. Was ebenfalls erscheinen wird noch im Laufe dieser Woche, ist ein Interview mit zwei Liverpooler Podcastern, Bloggern, YouTubern, die Anfitrap waren zu Gast in Sindelfingen. Ich habe mit ihnen gesprochen über Jürgen Klopp, was sich beim Liverpool FC so getan hat, wie sie auf das Champions-League-Achtelfinale gegen den FC Bayern vorausblicken. Das alles erscheint in Kürze auf rasen.de. Ich danke euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich bin gespannt auf eure Rückmeldungen.